m
le seul mec qui a déjà rêvé de sirat un
auteur parachute sa troupe la question
étant est-ce que c'est facile de rapper
en tombant vois-tu pas la musique pour
le meilleur rappeur je m'en fous par an
si je peux être le meilleur rapport
parachutistes keyless go
non
on
chalon sur saône entre dijon et lyon je
me trompe pas et on a un aérodrome du
coup c'est l'endroit où il ya une grosse
zone du causse au théâtre hier je suis
pas sur n'importe quoi et donc ici les
avions peuvent décoller et c'est le
morceau que j'ai choisie c'est un
morceau qui s'appelle prendre la vitesse
avant ce que j'ai fait avec un pote le
refrain c'est prendre la vitesse c'est
tout le champ lexical de ce qui peut
s'apparenter un peu à la chute libre
s'était pas fait exprès tu vois c'est un
truc très instructif et jeu mais je me
suis dit [ __ ] tout s'est alignée
parfaitement tout ça en brique et là
c'est le premier saut
au monde de freestyle enregistrés et
c'est là j'ai mon casque la radio qui
est branché directement aux récepteurs
ça c'est pour atterrir comme ça on peut
guider on peut m'avertir si les vents
changent
en co2 de secours donc j'apprends que
l'issue des tables d'hôtes en parachute
principal est ici tout l'ouverture de ce
poids donc ça va même si j'ai pas eu
besoin d'eux et puis ici talent à
la petite poignée là pour sortir le
chiffre qui ne faut pas à sa faim
beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
saleh sont donc j'ai cinquantaine de
secondes de chute libre
et
ses fils la durée de la musique on a
préparé la normalement je ferais
vérifier en vol altit à 0
au caire
on s'est compliqué parce que ta position
dans n'importe quel type de chanson du
rap ou quoi que ce soit elle est hyper
importante ce soit un endroit se situe
tirs à 6 déjà ta voix les bizarres là je
suis ni droit ni à si nicole chez soi je
suis comme ça tête haute ou clac la nuit
l'air que tu en voilà ils essaient
aurait des pires séquences mais tu vois
genre c'est comme ça les bras en l'air
les gens mon argent donc tu rappes comme
ça et surtout que c'est un ses musiques
très gestuelle tu vois et sa tête et là
je peux pas parce que si je fais ça je
fais ça
et je pense pas que les gens se rendront
bien content là quel point c'est
difficile
[Musique]
fêtons castres
gaillac
mais mes confort à tous
et puis là il tend la main et fait un
chéri vous fait un chèque laurent turcot
tend la main quel sens regarder puis
fait un chèque en disant non c'est
maintenant tu vas le largage il est
autorisé et la tendance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens bon sens veut que l'épaisseur 9 à
12 ans les concerts et bois de 10 tours
gens voient que le sol gelé
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au bout au top
la vie de ma mère c'est compliqué
complexe
impossible de se concentrer sur des
intentions de voix c'est dire que ce qui
sort de toi c'est juste ce qui peut sauf
que là où et tout l'impact du rap le
principe même musicale du rap c'est
l'interprétation c'est maman ça
ressemble à une dizaine ou qui est pas
fait pour ça ah j'étais en stress les
gars
au moment de mes looping parce que je
crois je vois le micro il va là il fait
et je le vois devant moi je fais hall
bâtard et tu perds pas la notion du
temps quand tu es dans l'air comme ça si
c'est très dur à gérer en fait le temps
passe hyper vite mais plus tu fais de ce
au plus tôt conscience du temps et là
maintenant je kiffe là quand j'étais
tout en haut tu es à 1500 mètres j'ai vu
surtout via le mont blanc là bas je
pense que c'est à vue puis cordero moi
je t'aime et tu kiffes tu es là tu dis
tu voles en fait nous quand on prépare
ce truc là on est confronté à mille et
un problèmes de kia mille et un
incident que tu dis ok ça ça passe ça va
pas sans dois faire ça ça doit faire ça
ok la voix le machin le truc leurs hôtes
c'est complexe de fous et plus on avance
dans le projet plus je me dis mais en
fait les gars c'est normal que ça n'a
pas été fait c'est trop chiant pour un
cristal genre d'une minute en fait
valoir que les gens se disent aux
récompenses studio là on est en train de
tomber ton berek déjà tu fais rien je
pense que là les gens se rendant pas
compte de ce que c'est et de tout
l'effort est tous dans un truc qui
finalement je veux juste dire ah ok ah
ouais c'est vrai d'autres bizarre allez
c'est ça qui va se passer et c'est ça
qui est frustrant mais nous on s'en fou
pour la beauté du sport et la beauté de
la
[Musique]